[Music]
right today I'm at Olmstead in the
middle of Brooklyn New York to catch up
with fellow chef Greg to discuss one of
the biggest shifts the restaurant
industry has seen in the last 20 years
for me every customer walks through my
doors is the critic and all my chefs are
obsessed with taking pictures of
ingredients and their finished dishes on
a daily basis that's why I'm teaming up
with Google pixel and the chances are
right now
you're probably watching this on your
phone quailed I'm gonna get you he's on
table 79 right before we get into the
ingredients restaurants and social media
I want to get into this the Google pixel
three now from a chest point of view I'm
always traveling around the world
looking for inspiration that's why this
can prove to be a very powerful tool now
that is beautiful they say the camera is
like no other but look at the design
it's slick it feels incredibly
comfortable but on top of that the
Google lens which when you're
photographing ingredients dishes they'll
actually tell you what it is right there
and then now whilst Greg is in the
kitchen whipping up a storm I'm dying to
get out of that garden in the middle of
bloody Brooklyn and see what in Greece I
can identify middle of Brooklyn and look
at this weather
reminds me of England Wow look at that
that is a beautiful quail let's see if
this phone can identify this plant here
and there it is right
poor poor I got that brilliant great
gonna see what's gonna see it oh you
well well yes
first of all congratulations nazar you
now have one of the most difference for
anyone to get into you know from a chefs
one of you we eat with our eyes
absolutely it looks vibrance before I
want to taste that you know what I'm
gonna do don't you
yeah sorry hopefully take a bit really
does that get you excited when these
pictures become viral and they go across
the world within seconds yeah I mean
it's flattering and it drives business
this pixel craze become my new sous chef
look at that I mean seriously
how beautiful is that's pretty you know
I teach all that cooks is that visual
impact yeah your hand porn is that for
you we tried to present food in a very
photogenic way but is still very
familiar this is a delicata squash so
what we do is we kind of treat it like
an onion ring so we just dip it it in
our own Furyk hockey and then we have
these little trees that looks beautiful
like one of the most glamorous Christmas
trees anywhere in the world our most
popular dish the only flavors are
sunflowers carrots and clams I'm sad
okay in the middle of London and one of
my chefs were here and took a picture of
this character SH and it looked
incredible what's so special about this
so this is carrot and clam juice we cook
the clams we take the clam juice we
reduced it with carrot juice and then we
combine it with carrot obliques that we
blaze in the clams themselves it's a
rather simple dish wow that looks
amazing
cockles and carrots it pops right quick
picture that looks beautiful it looks
like an oasis on the plate
hey Google please remind me to send this
picture of cockles and carrots to my
youngest thoughta Matilda all right I'll
add that to your reminders and one more
thing quick selfie with the team in the
garden please yes please
right quick selfie Jomon please thank
you right so because my all can't get in
widen the lens there we go right
excellent
[Music]
look even the fourth inkwells in shot
thanks to google pixel for the
partnership and don't forget to check
out the Google pixel 3 and the other
amazing videos across this series